zurück bei bild mit ihm mit christian
lindner dem bundesfinanzministerium mit
ihm sprechen wir natürlich auch qua amt
über die finanziellen folgen hier in
deutschland dieses ukraine krieges heute
an der tankstelle mit zwei vor dem komma
in weiten teilen deutschlands egal was
man tankt sogar auch beim diesel
teilweise sehen wir hier 2 19 sogar hier
bei diesen tankstellen 214 super also an
die zwei an die gewöhnen bei uns
offenbar an diesem wochenende und können
uns natürlich daran nicht gewöhnen
müssen sie tanken sie aktuell noch oder
hat sich das logischerweise als minister
im grunde erledigt doch ich war auch
noch
autorin immer relativ wenig auto
gefahren gerne aber wenig ich tanke
schon noch insofern kenne ich die
preisentwicklung wir schauen auf die
zuschauerfrage die nahe liegend ist
lindner
mein name ist doch wohl nur 56 jahren
erhalten habe eine frage
terminen ja schon gehört und wir sehen
ihn jetzt auch noch
ansonsten machen wir mit ihm weiter mit
frank löser denn diese frage kam 500 mal
klar ob ich frank löser der selber
landesbeamter fdp wähler ist schreibt
dazu er kann sie im grunde das tanken
bald nicht mehr leisten dann hat
natürlich eine schnelle lösung menschen
einfach steuern senken großteil des
spritpreises kommt doch vom staat
erlöser schreibt dass er 66 kilometer am
tag zur dienststelle pendelt und das ist
genau die arbeitende mitte in unserem
land die gegenwärtig belastet ist und
erlöser was möglich ist tun wir
das gab im grunde noch nie mitten am
laufenden jahr verändern wir ja das
steuerrecht
rückwirkend zum ersten januar wird der
steuerliche grundfreibetrag
um 363 euro
erhöht ist eine steuerentlastung erst
für haushalte nicht mal die inflation
kraus sagte gleich was zu außerdem die
arbeitnehmer der
arbeitnehmer-pauschbetrag wird erhöht
kern fern pendlerpauschale wird erhöht
und die eeg-umlage die noch mal auf den
strompreis drauf kommt wird abgeschafft
nun kommt die die
leider notwendige
zusätzliche botschaft
wenn die rohstoffpreise beim import nach
deutschland wachsen dann kann man das
übersetzen damit dass wir alle gemeinsam
ärmer werden wenn unser land insgesamt
mehr zahlen muss für rohstoffimporte zb
öl dann werden wir als land insgesamt
ärmer das kann der staat
eine zeit
abfedern wir können das sozial
ausbalancieren aber einen
volkswirtschaftlichen wohlstandsverlust
durch inflation insgesamt kann der staat
selbst der deutsche staat nicht auf
dauer ausgleichen okay aber das ist
einmal ganz kurz für uns übersetzt die
wahrheit ihr werdet tragen es gibt
dieses kleine entlastungsprogramm was
aber die inflation jetzt schon nicht
aufhängen und alle nach rechnungen nicht
komplett auffängt und das was jetzt oben
drauf kommt durch den ukraine krieg das
zahlen behindert tankstelle
es zahlt immer irgendjemand der staat
hat ja nur das geld das die bürgerinnen
und bürger ihm zur verfügung stellen das
ist schon klar heißt wir können ja das
ist es ist aber gut dass es der
finanzminister weiß das war vielleicht
im vergangenen jahr immer sein um ihr
das nicht immer so dass sie jetzt können
auch ein klein bisschen über die
kreditaufnahme aus der zukunft in der
notsituation auch noch dämpfen und
abfedern aber wir können eben nicht die
großen wirtschaftlichen entwicklungen
aufheben wir arbeiten nur mit dem geld
der bürger wir verteilen es etwas umwelt
federn ab der können kredite aufnehmen
aus der zukunft und deshalb muss unser
hauptaugenmerk darauf liegen dass wir
zusätzliche quellen von von energie
lieferungen erhalten dass wir die so
genannten freiheits energien wie ich
immer dazu sage also die erneuerbaren
energieträger in deutschland schnell
ausbauen das kann man tun aber die
folgen der inflation insgesamt abfedern
kann auch der deutschen bank profitieren
sie ja massiv davon das wissen auch ein
populärer irrtum naja sie nehmen
zumindest höhere steuereinnahmen eines
dem megane schauen wir schauen wir ob
der erhöhte möglicherweise in ihren
reihen auch vorkommt bei einer ich
übertreibe ein bisschen mitarbeiterin
von ihnen von einer bundesbeamten die
uns heute schreibt im vorfeld dieser
sendung das ist marica schaden müssen
sie nicht kennen sie sagt auch nur dass
sie eine untergeordnete behörde bei
ihnen arbeitet hallo herr lindner ich
bin als bundesbeamten für den deutschen
staat tätig und da stehe sogar ihrem
ressort inzwischen kann ich mir kaum
noch leisten mein auto zu tanken um zur
arbeit zu fahren geschweige denn mein
haus zu heizen also was gedenken sie nun
endlich dagegen zu über unternehmen und
da geht es eben auch wieder um die hohen
steuern die der polnische staat
interessanterweise gerade senken also
ich will versuchen die dinge noch ein
klein bisschen zu sortieren zum einen
was gedenken sie endlich zu tun sagt
frau charlene wir kommen ja gerade mit
einem milliardenpaket der entlastung
dass die vorgängerregierung nicht
geplant hat und das vermutlich niemand
dieser bundesregierung zugetraut das
heißt es gibt bereits eine milliarden
entlastung 12 die jetzt steigenden
preise haben auch etwas auch nicht nur
mit der mit dem ukraine krieg zu tun es
sind also auch kriegsfolgen von denen
wir gemeinsam ja gesagt haben wir sind
solidarisch das müssen wir also auch
miteinander
bewältigen wir werden sozial abfedern
wir versuchen zu dämpfen aber es gibt
grenzen denn und dass der dritte gedanke
die vorstellung dass der staat davon
profitiert ist ja nur die eine seite der
medaille
natürlich sind es höhere einnahmen bei
der umsatzsteuer auf energie
aber wenn menschen mehr zahlen müssen
für das benzin und der staat dafür
umsatzsteuer bekommt verzichten die
menschen leider ja auf anderes wofür der
staat dann keine umsatzsteuer bekommt
das heißt wer sein geld ausgeben muss
weil er trump
kauft vielleicht auf der anderen seite
von etwas anderem weniger und unter dem
strich hat der staat eben nicht mehr
geld dafür werden sie für die
argumentation werden die meisten an der
tankstelle verzeihen sie aber ich glaube
relativ wenig verstehe ich daneben ja
ich kann den euro nur einmal ausgeben
und ich muss es einfach unterstreichen
der staat kann nur das ausgeben was er
hat ich habe kein eigenes geld sondern
ich verteile das geld der bürgerinnen
und bürger also es gibt keinerlei
überlegungen derzeit die steuern auf
sprit zu senken nein
wo würden sie sagen ist eine grenze
erreicht wir gucken auf die zwei das war
schon immer an die scheuer als minister
hat da gesagt in seinen letzten
amtstagen als verkehrsminister da muss
die spritpreis bremse getreten werden
bei zwei euro jetzt immer darüber gibt
so etwas bei ihnen auch dass sie sagen
okay das ist der kipp punkt ab da ihr
kollege robert habeck hat auch vor
sozialen und gesellschaftlichen
verwerfungen gewarnt wenn man jetzt im
zuge von sanktionen massive
preissteigerungen erlebt also gibt es
diesen punkt bei ihnen wo sie sagen okay
dann müssen wir doch helfen ich will
noch mal ihre zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer in erinnerung rufen dass sie
gerade im ersten teil der sendung
gesprochen haben über ein embargo bei
energielieferungen deutschland würden
die preise massiv steigen so ist es ja
und jetzt kommen sie bei der e mails von
ihnen wissen oder deren gibt die
karriere ja nur bei den preisen die wir
jetzt haben sagen sie schon wann kommt
die entlastung und gerade eben im ersten
teil haben wir darüber gesprochen nehmen
wir eigentlich in kauf oder müssten wir
nicht alle in kauf nehmen dass sie noch
höher steigen
was man nicht tun kann ist zu sagen wir
wollen auf der einen seite import
stoppen aber die folgen für alle muss
der staat übernehmen das kann er nicht
wenn ich die möglichkeit hätte wenn ich
eine geldreserve hetze wo ich sagen kann
jetzt kompensieren wir das alles und
niemand merkt würde ich es gerne machen
ich erkenne die sorgen und nöte der
pendlerinnen und pendler ich betreibe
keine politik gegen das auto ich komme
selbst aus dem ländlichen raum und weiß
es gibt menschen die wollen nicht nur
autofahren sondern sie müssen auch jeden
tag autofahren und aus diesem grund
haben wir erreicht dass es anders als
von der vorgängerregierung die übrigens
von der cdu csu geführt war geplant dass
wir jetzt ein entlastungspaket in diesem
jahr bekommen zum ersten ersten des
nächsten jahres wird es weitere
veränderungen geben beim regelsatz der
grundsicherung beim steuer steuerliche
existenzminimum
beziehungsweise dem grundfreibetrag und
auch beim steuertarif aber jetzt für
dieses jahr haben wir ein paket
geschnürt und nun gilt was ich eben noch
sagte zusätzlich zusätzliche
lieferquellen nach deutschland
erschließen erneuerbare freiheits
energien ausbauen um dadurch die energie
preissteigerung zu reduzieren also in
sondervermögen spritpreis ist nicht drin
das wäre mit dem grundgesetz nicht
vereinbar ich frage deswegen weil das in
vielen zuschauer zuschriften kamen dass
man sagt gar keine kritik daran an der
bundeswehr die muss natürlich stärker
ausgestattet werden völlig richtig aber
da sind mal eben mit einem kniff bei
ihnen wird es ein bisschen schwieriger
seinem ministerium dass gerade
herauszufinden wie genau dieser kniff
gehen sollen 100 milliarden knapp aber
es gibt diesen kniff und plötzlich ist
die kohle dafür die bundeswehr für die
man über jahrzehnte kein geld hatte also
kannst du auch diesen kniff auch für
autofahrer geben dieser kniff ist kein
trick sondern ist eine notwendige
entscheidung und ich übersetze das noch
einmal wir leihen uns geld aus der
zukunft neben der schuldenbremse um die
lange vernachlässigung der bundeswehr
angesichts der bedrohung unserer äußeren
sicherheit zu beenden und das ist ein
schwerer schritt weil das geld ist nicht
da wir leihen es uns aus der zukunft ich
bin nicht dafür dass wir für die
gegenwärtig gestiegenen spritpreise
jetzt gewissermaßen bei unseren enkeln
einen kredit nehmen das geht nicht das
lässt auch das grundgesetz nicht zu und
ich muss es leider noch einmal sagen
gestiegene preise für rohstoffe kann man
übersetzen mit wir alle werden ärmer das
ganze land wird ärmer wenn wir alle
gemeinsam mehr zahlen müssen für
rohstoffe und das kann der staat nur
abfedern umverteilen aber er kann es
nicht aufheben weil übrigen der staat ja
selber auch mehr zahlt die ja das wollte
ich gerade eben noch ausführen nicht nur
dass für die mehrwertsteuer die wir mehr
einnahmen auf mehrwertsteuer aus anderem
fehlt natürlich hat der staat auch
höhere sozialleistungen zu zahlen die ja
an die inflation angepasst werden auch
die investitionen des staates werden
teurer das heißt der staat ist nicht nur
profiteur von inflationär wird auch
belastet durch inflation weshalb wir
alles unternehmen müssen um keine
spirale der preisentwicklung zu bekommen
noch einmal ganz kurz auf diese
sondervermögen bundeswehr zwischen zu
kommen dann wird das im gesetz als
gesetzentwurf von ihnen fertig sein dann
werden sie diesen was ich genannt habe
kniff fertig haben
innerhalb der nächsten drei tage
wir haben heute einen vorschlag gehört
von ihrem verkehrsminister gehört und
gelesen in der bild am sonntag der zielt
auf die versorgung der ukraine vor allen
dingen die versorgung der hauptstadt
kiew das wird uns in den nächsten
stunden schon beschäftigen da haben wir
schon am freitag am donnerstag die
leeren regale gesehen dort fängt man in
diesen tagen an zu tauschen was man noch
hat und der notstand wird er sehr
schnell erreicht sein es sollen züge
fahren von deutschland in die ukraine
rein wie kann das gehen züge in ein
gebiet in dem krieg herrscht wo man gar
nicht weiß wo die leute alle rausdrängen
aktuell haben sie eine idee wie das
funktionieren kann wie die güter
tatsächlich ankommen können wie die züge
geschützt werden können nein das weiß
ich nicht
das ist eine sache der zuständigen
kollegen und auch der sicherheitskräfte
mich hat nur als ich das in den letzten
tagen gehört habe von volker wissing und
anderen hat mir das soll ich sagen
dass gezeigt dass da eine hohe
sensibilität da ist dass wir es nicht
bei worten belassen
wenn es um die hilfe für die ukraine
geht da sind jetzt sehr ungewöhnliche
maßnahmen auch schwierige maßnahmen will
noch mal an das gespräch mit dem
bürgermeister erinnern als ich sagte
dass wir aus solidarität mit der ukraine
unsere jahrzehnte gültige doktrin bei
den waffenlieferungen verändert haben
und das was jetzt folgt bei der
versorgung der ukraine ist ebenfalls ja
eine unkonventionelle aber notwendige
maßnahme